welcome back to the David Pakman show
happening now or at least at the time of
this recording Attorney General William
Barr is testifying before the before
Congress and we got it we obtained a
clip of Barr refusing to answer the
question of whether or not the White
House itself actually saw the Muller
report now you can recall everyone knows
the Muller report was a 22 month process
an investigation and instead of
releasing the report William Barr
released a four-page summary and Donald
Trump said that this summary exonerated
him completely or rather he said that
the report exonerated him completely but
representative needle owie
asked asked William Barnes just a moment
ago did the White House see the report
before you released your summarizing
letter has the White House seen it since
have they been briefed on the contents
beyond what was your summarizing letter
and bar refused to answer let's take a
quick look at this clip that's did the
White House see the report before you
released your summarizing letter has the
White House seen it since then
have they been briefed on the contents
beyond what was in you a summarizing
letter to the Judiciary Committee I've
said what I'm going to say about the
report today I've three letters about it
and I was willing to discuss the
historic information of how the report
came to me in my decision on Sunday but
I've already laid out the process that
is going forward to release these
reports hopefully within a week and I'm
not going to say anything more about it
until the report is out and everyone has
a chance to look at it so Attorney
General Barr is making it clear that
this is a question that he cannot answer
IIIi don't you know we can parse it
however you want to parse it but he
refuses to answer this and this is
important because this cut to this cuts
to what we discussed in a previous
segment where
Donald Trump set the narrative by saying
he's been fully exonerated media outlets
picked up this narrative spread it
around as though it was absolutely the
fact matter of fact also as though
they've read the summary or rather read
the Mullah report themselves well now it
turns out it sounds like the President
of the United States himself has not
read the report or anyone in the White
House the question was a general
question did the White House see the
report and I just did Donald Trump see
the report but did the White House see
the report and the bar was not willing
to answer something else that we can
glean from this brief exchange is the
fact that it looks as though they are
gearing up to release the report because
of all the pressure that's being mounted
against them the attempt to keep this as
private as they possibly could it looks
as though they're going to have to
release the report the question is how
much of the report will be redacted
right how much of the White House how
much is the White House going to redact
it so at some point whether or not Trump
has seen it yet they're going to see it
and they're going to be given the
opportunity to redact as much
information as they would like
well if Donald Trump was completely
exonerated then by all means release the
entire report this is the frustrating
part about journalism about media about
politics in general we needed the media
to do their job and to point out these
inconsistencies and the glaring
hypocrisy of us having to take at face
value a summary versus the full report
right we who else is going to hold
political power accountable if the media
is not and while the media took the last
several weeks to slam dunk on MSNBC
probably rightfully so will it still
remains to be seen
right to slam dunk on everyone who
believed that there was anything to the
Russia probe at all they should have
been pointing out the fact that we have
not seen the report too concretely and
to definitively say that
Donald Trump has been exonerated what
they did instead was take the
president's word for it and use that for
a new cycle in which they lambasted
anyone who believed anything about the
Russia probe whatsoever and now it turns
out that it looks as though that the
White House itself has not seen the full
report or has not read the full report
at least according to the exchange that
we just saw between bar and Congress
person LOI this this is just another
another another important point in a
series of important points that shows
you several things that shows you that
the President of the United States
absolutely does have something to hide
whether or not it is it is impeachable
we see you know that that is a political
question right that is a political
question in terms of whether or not it
met the legal bar to indict him we see
that it did not meet the legal bar to
indict him according to robert muller
but we also know that there's been this
that there's been indictable offences or
rather there's been impeachable offenses
that have not met the indictment bar so
you know I I for one if you go back to
my catalogue of videos my number one
thing always was hey let's let this play
out let's let the mullet probe play
itself out and see what information we
get from it and here we've let allowed
it to play out at least I have without
you know most of us have done it without
jumping on the bandwagon of the the
hysteria but at the same time not
dismissing it you know there's an entire
contingency of
so-called objective journalists who have
been dismissing it and have taken an
active role in dismissing the entire
malla probe as nothing more than
conspiracy and yet here we have the
Attorney General of the United States of
America saying well first of all being a
barrier to sing in the full report and
now saying that we don't even know if
the White House has read the report
where are the journalists who are going
to say hold up wait a minute there's
something going on here that we need to
get to the bottom of I don't know
they're too busy slam dunking because
you know we the report did not prove
that Donald Trump was an actual
Manchurian Candidate being controlled by
Russia and because he wasn't an actual
mentor in candidate being controlled by
Russia then there's nothing to see here
well there's still some smoke here and
the smoke is the fact that Barr was
placed into position to block this
report from coming out and it did
exactly what he was there to do which
was to muddy the waters enough for a new
cycle long enough for us to get to the
point where we move on from it and now
the rest of this is just kind of
secondary conversations